Hello.
I'm going to talk to you about the semi-conservative replication of DNA,
not so much about the technical details,
but about how Frank Stahl and I ended up doing the experiment
that showed that DNA replicates by the two chains coming apart,
each making a new copy and then you get two, each of which has one
old chain and one new one.
It's hard to know where to start any particular story,
but let me start with the publication in 1953 of the paper by
Watson and Crick.
There were actually two papers in Nature.
The first was about the structure,
which was based on model building and a little bit of information from X-ray
diffraction.
The X-ray diffraction certainly did not tell you the structure,
it told you something about the repeat distance along the helix, it told you that it
was a helix, and very little more.
The model building was model building,
so the structure certainly wasn't proven.
This was a proposal,
and many people didn't believe it, or maybe didn't even pay any attention to it.
The second paper proposed how the molecule might replicate-- the two
chains would separate,
each would guide on its surface the formation of a new chain.
And so you end up with two double helices,
each one has one of the old chains and one brand new chain. That's called
semi-conservative replication.
At Caltech,
Max Delbrück,
who knew Jim Watson, was in correspondence with him,
was pessimistic about this replication scheme,
pessimistic about semi-conservative replication.
The chains were wound around each other,
so to get them apart,
unless you break them,
you'd have to unwind the basic double helix to get the two arms separate.
Max thought this would be impossible,
hydrodynamically impossible.
And so he proposed that maybe the two chains separate by a system of breaking
every several nucleotides along the chain.
And he and Gunther Stent published a paper which proposed three different methods
for DNA replication:
semi-conservative,
as Watson and Crick had predicted,
conservative in which, at least conceptually,
maybe there was a way that a double helix could guide the formation of another double helix
just like it nearby and so you never have to separate the
chains at all,
you'd have brand new double helix and a completely old double helix,
and that would be the active replication, and then dispersive,
the third way, break that single chains separate the pieces
and then put everything back together again.
I visited Max in his office.
I was in chemistry.
I was a student of Linus Pauling.
Max was over in biology and he told me about this problem.
And it occurred to me that maybe one could do an experiment to find out the
mode of replication of DNA based on the use of heavy isotopes.
I wish I had time to tell you about why I thought about heavy isotopes,
but it did have to do with taking a course,
which was a piece of luck,
Linus Pauling's course on the nature of the chemical bond, in which deuterium and
hydrogen bonds played an important role.
Nevertheless,
the idea was to label DNA with something heavy,
I don't think I thought about--
yes,
it was deuterium I thought about at the time,
and then to label it by growing bacteria,
or phages, in heavy medium, deuterium medium,
and then switch the growth to light medium,
and then put all of this in the centrifuge and look to see where the DNA went. Up
to the top-- if you adjusted the density right--
if it was all light, down to the bottom if it was all heavy, and in the middle if
it was half heavy and half light.
That's an oversimplification,
but that's the way I thought about the experiment at that time.
This was around 1954 sometime. I then went to Woods
Hole as a teaching assistant for Jim Watson,
he had lived at Caltech the previous term,
in the physiology course.
And one day as a teaching assistant in that course,
Jim Watson and Sydney Brenner,
who were teaching the course,
were in an upstairs room in the building called the Lillie Building at
the Marine Biological Lab,
and Jim looked through the window and pointed down at a tree under which was sitting a man.
He had a big jug of gin and a big thing of tonic and some ice and glasses;
it was called the gin and tonic tree.
But Jim was saying,
this guy thought pretty much of himself,
so let's give him a really tough experiment to do in the physiology class-- the famous
Hershey-Chase experiment, done by two people over a period of time,
Hershey and Chase. See if Stahl could do it all in one afternoon by himself.
Well,
I thought that was pretty rotten to gang up on this poor guy so I went down and introduced
myself to him and told him what lay in store for him.
And he told me what he was doing in phage genetics,
and he would be at Caltech that next year.
So we agreed to try to do this experiment together, ourselves, on how DNA replicates
when he got to Caltech.
I had to finish my X-ray crystallography first before Frank would let us start because
he said it would be bad for my character to go ahead and start some new project when I
hadn't finished my my thesis work,
which was X-ray crystallography.
Finally,
I got the X-ray crystallography done,
and we could start the experiment.
Frank and I decided that we should develop the method for doing this density gradient centrifugation,
and so we spent quite a long time, more than a year, developing a method that could separate
macromolecules in a density gradient. And to do that we put in pure DNA
into a centrifuge,
we turned it on to see what was happening,
and to our amazement,
a density gradient was forming before our very eyes.
This was because the cesium ion is quite heavy,
quite dense,
and it tends to settle to the bottom in a powerful centrifugal field and
diffusion wants it to go back up to redistribute it. And at equilibrium,
you have a density gradient in which there's more cesium chloride near the bottom than
near the top.
And so the density gradient forms automatically.
We didn't expect this when we saw it happen.
We thought we'd have to make a preformed density gradient in the centrifuge
cell.
But the centrifuge itself makes the density gradient.
So to make a long story short,
we grew bacteria in heavy nitrogen medium,
and then after many generations of growth so that everything would be
labeled with heavy nitrogen,
we switched the bacteria centrifuging them and resuspending them in light
medium and took samples at various times.
The first experiment, Frank had warned me I would mix it up if I did both
directions at once,
that is heavy to light and light to heavy.
And I said,
no,
I'll color code the tubes.
I mixed it up completely,
so it was unclear exactly which tubes were which.
The second experiment we labeled Experiment Number 1,
and that's what we published,
along with Experiment Number 2,
which was a repeat.
And what we found,
of course,
was that the bacteria at one generation
had only one kind of DNA.
It had a density halfway between heavy and light.
And in the second bacterial generation,
there were two kinds of DNA, half heavy and fully light.
What we did was blessed by a lot of accidents.
The accident of being at Caltech,
the accident of meeting each other at Woods Hole,
the accident of having Max Delbrück impress you with his deep pessimism
that DNA couldn't possibly replicate the Watson and Crick way, the way it does,
and finally,
the accident of finding out that the centrifuge itself will make a density gradient,
you don't have to make a preexisting one.
Now we had to write this paper up.
Actually,
we were rather sluggish in writing it up and so Max Delbrück took us to the marine lab of
Caltech at Corona Del Mar and locked us up in a tower room, literally did.
Mary Delbrück,
Max's wife, would bring us meals, but then lock the door again
until we-- and there was a typewriter-- until we produced a draft manuscript,
which we did.
The effect of this experiment is worth saying something about. When the DNA structure was
proposed,
a lot of people didn't believe it,
and there were not a lot of references to it in the literature for the first several years after
1953.
After all,
it was based on model building,
which doesn't prove anything.
It looked so beautiful that some people were convinced that it had to be right because
it looked so right.
Other people,
I think, were convinced it couldn't be right because it looked too good to be true.
In any case,
it was just a model.
The evidence from the X-ray diffraction was really not very supportive.
It showed that repeat distance was a certain distance and that it was helical,
but you couldn't deduce any of the details from those early X-ray pictures.
I think the effect of our experiment wasn't really a discovery,
it was a psychological effect.
It made the DNA seem real. Suddenly you could see bands in a
centrifuge that were behaving just the way Watson and Crick said they should.
And I think that the main value of the experiment was it had the
psychological value of convincing a lot of people that the DNA
structure had to be right.
Let me say something about that molecule.
This molecule essentially gave orders to a whole period in the
development of molecular biology.
Here's this double helix standing there,
and it's saying,
"Here I am,
I have two chains,
go find out how I replicate.
Here I am,
I have four kinds of bases,
go figure out how that is converted into making proteins.
I sit in the nucleus,
proteins are made out of the cytoplasm in eukaryotes, go figure out what it is that takes this
information from me out to the cytoplasm. My information being made up of these
bases changes once in a while,
that's called mutation,
go figure out how that happens.
Every once in a while,
there's something called genetic recombination,
go figure out how I'm..." What I'm trying to say here is that if I showed you a model of, say,
a polysaccharide,
would it tell you what experiment you should do next?
This molecule DNA is like the Wizard of Oz, standing there,
except unlike the Wizard this is a true molecule, standing there and telling
you essentially the whole agenda for the future of science for the
next 20 years.
That's a completely different mood and attitude,
I think, from the science that went before it and the biological science that came after
it.
So that was the characteristic of this time. It was the DNA molecule telling you what the
problems were,
what you had to go out and solve.